for a century the Titanic has been
hidden in darkness
two and a half miles down
at the bottom of the Atlantic
now a new investigation is about to
drain the ocean pull the plug of the
Atlantic
and reveal the wreck
the Titanic as she's never been seen
before
and in the bright light of day we
uncover critical New pieces of evidence
not previously visible
from giant gouges on the ocean floor to
iceberg that sliced her open a team of
scientists equipped with Cutting Edge
tools now tackles the long-standing
mysteries of the disaster that could
rewrite the Titanic's story
drain Drive
of the Titanic as you've never
used before
[Music]
it's the most infamous ship in all
history
the Titanic
from a time when ocean liners are racing
to be the biggest fastest and best
the RMS Titanic
the technological mark
when she sets sail in 1912
it's the largest moving man-made object
on the planet
an unsinkable ship
but around two and a half thousand miles
into her maiden voyage disaster
500 passengers and crew dragged down to
the icy depths
and more than a century later we still
don't know exactly what happened that
night
how's she saying and broke apart
hundreds of passengers and crew
witnessed the tragedy and lived to tell
the tale
yet countless unanswered questions
remain
we have lots of historical information
but often there are biases in in those
historical accounts even the
eyewitnesses of the sinking of Titanic
had many different perceptions of how
that sinking took place so the best way
to unravel some of those those questions
is to use science
explorers first discovered the Titanic's
wreckage in September 1985.
[Music]
all right
since then more than 20 Expeditions have
gone back to the ship
two and a half miles down
this is a place as alien as the surface
of the Moon
only a few yards of the Titanic's Hull
are visible in an Explorer's headlights
at any one time
[Music]
nobody's ever been able to see the whole
wreck or even find the edges of the site
trying to understand Titanic with the
existing technology was like trying to
draw a map of downtown Manhattan
from the height of a 10-story building
in a vehicle that has the windows fogged
up
pitch black and you're trying to look at
it through a flashlight
challenging to say the least
critical Clues to understanding the
disaster still lurk in this Darkness
now a team of scientists funded by the
legal Steward of the wreck RMS Titanic
Inc
are set to change all that
and bring the Titanic into the clear
light of day for the first time
an epic high-tech investigation to
discover exactly how and why she sang
the Titanic mapping project
the mission use Cutting Edge sonar
mapping technology to scan every part of
the wreck and build a precise Digital
model of the Titanic
sits on the ocean floor
their data will allow us to virtually
peel back the sea
strip away trillions of gallons of the
Atlantic Ocean
two and a half miles down
feel the unsinkable Titanic
drain dry
but scanning the deep ocean isn't easy
autonomous underwater vehicles auvs have
to dive down through 12 000 feet of
water
it's incredibly challenging to work at
Titanic it's dangerous it's a very
dangerous place
investigators programmed the auvs to fly
as close as 30 feet above the red
the underwater drones then fire signals
measuring variations in height down to
the tiniest detail
they crisscross the rank and seabed like
mowing a gigantic lawn
each pass scans a 150 foot wide strip
Gathering millions of data points
next the team deploys an ROV a remote
controlled sub attached by cable to
capture thousands of digital images of
every point on the wreck
every single day these vehicles would
come back with some new bit of
information about what was on the bottom
tidal wave of new data comes to the
surface
within 160 hours of video
in total 37 terabytes of data
but to see what they've got
takes time
over the next week Banks of computers
crunched the raw data
turning millions of sonar points into a
complex model of the wreck
I remember all of us sort of sitting
around the computer when we first were
building the 3D layer and seeing the bow
and seeing the stern in so much detail
we were all sort of grinning at the
screen looking at all that data and
seeing that for the first time was was
pretty amazing
at the same time
visualization expert Bill Lang begins
stitching together thousands of
individual images of the wreck
a task that takes him and his team at
Woods Hole oceanographic institution six
months to complete
it's a very long and tedious process
there were over 200 other mosaics that
were done for site interpretation and
and future archaeological work
this ultra high def imagery together
with the 3D scan
can now unlock a new vision of the
Titanic a wreck that's been shrouded in
darkness for over a century
it's been four years in the making
and now we can strip bear an
extraordinary landscape
pull the plug from the Atlantic
[Music]
and a half miles down
giant walls of steel Tower into the sky
sunlight hits her decks once more
countless Clues to the disaster start to
emerge
is the drain drag
of the Titanic
we've drained the Titanic
and for the first time
and see the ship in its entirety an
unprecedented detail
now investigators can map out the site's
boundaries
and archaeologists get an overview of a
wreck that's been hidden for more than
100 years
it's almost like the fog has been
cleared away and can now start to see
through the Perpetual Darkness
the idea of draining of the Titanic
presents the site in a whole different
life it's not impenetrable it's right
there in front of us to explore
the Titanic's wreckage has spread out
over half a square mile of the exposed
ocean floor
an area of some 200 soccer fields
the site of RMS Titanic it can be
described pretty basically as two large
features
the bow section
and the stern section
which are about a half a mile apart and
then numerous debris fields
in all there are five debris fields
each scattered with fragments of the
ship
and objects that tumbled out as she sang
Vistas Unleashed by the new model bring
the Titanic back to life with the water
Stripped Away
story is laid out in plain sight
people think science is above emotion
you know when you're looking at the boat
deck where you know so many people say
goodbye to one another these are
important points on that ship
the guard rails
where on that freezing night fathers
hugged their children set them in the
lowering lifeboats
and leaned out to catch a final glimpse
of their loved ones
portholes were passengers trapped below
deck saw the Starry Sky for the last
time
as the ship slipped beneath the waves
and even the Mast of the crowsness where
Lookout Frederick fleet's voice
shattered The Silence of the night
as he first spotted the looming iceberg
the Titanic's iconic eight and a half
ton anchors still in place
gleam in the bright daylight for the
first time in over a century
and with the ocean now sucked dry
her enormous spouse section Towers above
the seabed
despite the violence of the sinking and
all that time on the bottom what's
inside that bowel in particular is
still a ghostly sense
of the ship that was
inside the bow were many of the most
luxurious of the ship's features
the grand staircase running the height
of five decks
[Music]
heated swimming pool
reserved for first-class passengers only
[Music]
and a state-of-the-art gym
positioned right up on the boat deck
the model reveals just how intact this
section of the ship really is
[Music]
embedded in the exposed ocean floor
almost perfectly upright
ghostly shell of the Titanic seems to be
sailing across the seabed her prowl
parting the mud almost like water
[Music]
with 40 feet of the bow above the ocean
floor a full 60 feet must be buried
equivalent to a six-story building
using the depth which had carved into
the seabed investigators are refining
their calculations of the impact speed
its descent was very smooth it had its
aerodynamic nose facing into the
direction of travel
so there was no tumbling it was not
particularly violent until the very last
moment
one separated from the rest of the ship
the bowel sank first at about 35 miles
per hour at an angle of 15 to 30 degrees
its impact with the sea floor was like a
gigantic 31 000 ton truck slamming into
a snow drift
with the bow finally reached the bottom
it plowed in to the dirt almost all the
way up to the anchors
with the darkness of the deep drained
away it's Crystal Clear
here the impact is Frozen in Time
the investigation is still probing the
data hoping to learn more about how the
bow reached the bottom
the fact that the bow is intact
that they can also examine the most
iconic mystery of the Titanic the
iceberg impact
the official 1912 accident report seems
to suggest the iceberg tore a gigantic
300-foot gash in the ship's right hand
side
ripping open more than a third of her
entire Hull
however eyewitness records proved the
Titanic took around two and a half hours
to sink
investigators are puzzled a 300 foot
hole would surely have sunk the Titanic
in a matter of minutes
Oceanic Explorer phn archelay has made
30 trips 12 000 feet down to the Titanic
but he's never seen a 300-foot gash
we were trying to find where the Titanic
hit the Heisenberg why it was like that
why we saw we saw some crack why is
there is a crack here and not here
Marshall Lee and the team now turn to
the ultra high resolution photo mosaics
of the wreckage
to see what evidence there might be
this profile view of the bow is stitched
together from over 3 000 individual
images
the profile mosaics show Titanic in a
way that that people hadn't seen it
before no one had done a profile view of
Titanic's bow in the 25 years that
people have been going to Titanic
here again even with these pen Sharp
Images they find no sign of anything
approaching a 300 foot tear on the hull
however when they turned to the video
footage investigators can see much
smaller areas of impact damage
foreign
damage appears to be confined to a maybe
a 30-foot length of the bow wasn't like
a gash and it wasn't tens of small gases
the size of these gaps in the hull adds
up to just 11 square feet
I breached this size would allow 370
gallons of seawater to gush in every
second
and when they analyze how quickly this
would have sunk the Titanic
turns out to be two and a half hours
exactly the time the ship actually took
to safe
an enduring mystery is solved
litigations further confirmed
that the giant gash is fiction
and that the iceberg made only small
punctures below the water line
together were enough to trigger disaster
for the team there's an even bigger
question looming that our new model
could shed light on
ship get torn in half
how did her valve become separated from
her Stern by a staggering two thousand
feet
the answer is here in broad daylight
drain seafloor
in the exposed record of the Titanic
we're peeling back the Atlantic Ocean
draining its Waters to reveal the
wreckage of the Titanic
this is what the ship looks like today
without two and a half miles of Pitch
Black Ocean blocking out the Sun
two thousand feet beyond the massive bow
section
in the heart of the debris Fields lays
the dismembered Stern the back end of
the ship
it's the second largest fragment
392 feet long
it's immediately obvious that it's in
very different condition than the bowel
the stern is a mess it looks like it's
been ripped up like confetti
[Music]
the stir today is pure chaos
some of the Stern's huge metal
components are still intact like the
40-foot High engines each the size of a
large house
[Music]
detailed model also shows decks collapse
crushed together
heavy steel beams twisted and torn like
straws
it's hard to figure out what you're
looking at to me it almost looks like a
giant pieces of metal sitting on the sea
floor but tough to make it out as a
piece of a ship
why is it in such bad condition
investigators have struggled to fully
explain this
the stern section has its problems and
interpretation because it's so
completely broken up
but within the model there's a vital
clue something that could unlock the
Stern's violent story
on the acoustic map you can see that the
stern was turning counter clock
it's a massive Mark carved into the
seabed
and the stern made impact
scientists can now read the tracks and
interpret how the stern impacted the
seafloor
you can see very well when the stern
hits the bottom the stone was still
turning and you can see the bottom of
the ship on port side showing that the
stone was turning in same time
the marks allow investigators to work
out the speed of impact
earn was moving through the water at 50
miles per hour
massive forces from the ship chaotically
whipping through the ocean at such speed
help explain why the stern is so badly
damaged
while the hydrodynamic bow sliced
cleanly through the water and remained
largely intact
if you have a claim it's damaged in
Flight
the air will get under the skin of the
plane and rip pieces off
the same thing would likely have
happened with the Titanic's rapidly
disintegrating Stern
at first large chunks came off
and then once the structure resisted
small pieces like confetti started to
fly away
investigators think high pressure water
they then have found a route into the
ship's internal structure slamming into
its interior walls
once the hull is separated from the
frames
water Will Blast through a little form
of ram all those interior walls were
wooden and they didn't stand a chance
the Water started coming through at full
force they were pulverized
to the team this is more evidence of why
the stern now looks like a massive car
wreck
while the bow section remains intact
it's another answer to the mystery
the investigation has now clarified how
the two main sections of the ship reach
the bottom
it's also shown how they impact why they
look so completely different
major question to tackle how and when
did the Titanic break apart
[Music]
with Cutting Edge technology we've
drained the depths of the Atlantic Ocean
and expose the final resting place of
the Titanic
after 100 Years of Darkness
her decks once more bask in the warmth
of the Sun
between the bow and Stern
massive debris field stretches out for
hundreds of feet
for the investigators
it's a view they've never seen before
every piece is a potential clue in
solving the mystery of how and why the
Titanic broke apart
for years the dominant theory has been
that she split in two on the surface
as the sinking bow angled down
lifting the stern high in
High its own unsupported weight became
too much the ship snapped in half
but with the ocean now drained away
Clues are emerging that could challenge
that theory
by looking at the pattern in which the
debris fell to the ocean floor
investigators can retrace the way it
fell from the ship
they'll use this Forensic Record to get
an accurate picture of how and when the
boat tore itself to pieces
getting the answer or require a massive
effort
the team must scan all the new
underwater data to ID and tag the
position of as many objects as possible
[Music]
and build a massive digital map of the
artifacts from the ocean floor
it includes the positions of the 5000 or
so objects previous Expeditions have
recovered from the wreck
it's a catalog of treasures
ornate statues from the ship's Grand
stairway
chandeliers that once hung in the first
class smoking room
finest Crockery from the ship's best
restaurant
there's even one of the Titanic's bronze
Bells
[Music]
this is of nautical equipment from the
docking Bridge
every precious object is a critical data
point
could help rewrite the story of how the
ship came apart
the patterns that are emerging from this
remapping of the site don't fit any of
the traditional models that were there
before
the work will take years to complete
[Music]
coffee cups dinner plates bits of
chandeliers deck benches that's full of
objects from the ship but also personal
objects as well
each data point on the map is also a
story in itself
a touchstone that reveals the detail of
a human life
these were all real people who had Lives
who had people who loved them
families who were impacted by what
happened on that night
some artifacts are highly personal
delicate jewelry that may have once
graced the neck of a society lady
and perfume bottles with their precious
liquid still inside
it's just a very beautiful
very emotional moment just to see
everything lying there on the ground
it's a visual story of that tragedy
after years of research Alex klingel
author is now able to tie some of these
belongings to specific named individuals
this is a pocket watch an open face
styled watch this one still has its
hands it probably stopped when it was
immersed in the water the watch came
from this spot in a debris field Eleven
Hundred feet southeast of the stern
it belonged to Thomas Williams Solomon
Brown
he was a hotelier from South Africa and
he was headed with his family to make a
new start in the western part of the
United States
he did not survive
however his wife and his daughter Edith
did
[Music]
other passengers Left Behind written
traces of their lives
still legible after a century in the
water
a notebook found 780 feet from the stern
in the west debris field belonged to a
young third-class passenger Edgardo
Samuel Andrew
foreign
he was 17 years old
when you look at his belongings you find
school books you can still see the
writing in here even though it's quite
stained he used a pencil and the pencil
has remained legible
here on this page he's writing his name
I guess practicing writing his name in
the correct way
you begin to see just this young boy so
in Third Class by Himself to America
Edgardo was hoping to make a better life
for himself like so many immigrants
traveling to the new world
unfortunately Edgar did not survive the
voyage
that's why this is perhaps such a
heart-rending object because it's his
last notations he's finished with school
he throws his school books into this
suitcase and he heads off to America and
that's the last that we hear of him
there are many more objects the team
hopes to examine further some with the
potential to flesh out the human face of
the tragedy
oftentimes history
swallows up
the ordinary folks all of us
we just tend to go away
archaeological sites give us an
opportunity to correct that
now that the investigation has defined
this ghostly place as an archaeological
site it will help them protect the
Titanic story for generations to come
each of the Priceless artifacts is part
of a mosaic of tragic stories
together form a picture
the fully mapped debris field is at last
ready to give investigators The crucial
answer they've long been waiting for
when and where the Titanic broke apart
in the two and a half hours it took the
Titanic to sink more than 700 people
made it off the ship and into lifeboats
hundreds of these survivors witnessed
the sinking
yet there's always been disagreement
about how and when the ship broke apart
there are still different theories and
arguments as to how things exactly
happened when the ship tore into
now some investigators think the new
data could prove once and for all what
really happened
in recent years the dominant theory has
been that the breakup occurred while the
Titanic was still on the surface
we know from eyewitnesses the stern
tilted up out of the water as she sang
some experts have argued this created
immense stresses tearing the ship into
but Bill Lang now thinks otherwise
according to him
the new data paints a different picture
on the drained ocean floor are all the
clues he needs
to build's trained eye there's nothing
random about the patterns of the debris
field like blood spatters at a crime
scene they tell a story
now flooded in daylight for the first
time with every last corner of the
debris field scanned and analyzed he can
work out how the Titanic really sang
to tell us a lot more about what
happened to the ship after it left the
surface
foreign
made this two and a half mile descent to
the sea floor and hopefully tell us more
about what happened to Titanic during
its breakup
for Bill the new images of the exposed
ocean floor make a key piece of evidence
visible for the first time
the overall scale of the debris field
the new survey definitively Maps the
site and for the first time
investigators can see its precise
dimensions
not quite the size they expected
I think the the site really isn't that
big when you consider the size of the
ship I mean we've got a almost thousand
foot long ship that's in two square
miles
the ship had fully separated on the
surface Bill thinks there'd be a much
larger scatter area
considering that it fell a few miles
through water column I think that the
scattering of of artifacts is rather
small
the lower and the water the separation
the less distance for debris to spread
out as it falls and the more compact the
pattern on the ocean floor
it's a straightforward argument
and for Bill it's evidence the ship
separated much deeper in the water than
previously thought
the only way he can explain the small
scatter pattern
one of the most important things I think
that's come out of us is that the ship
may not have broken up as fast and as
shallow as as what was originally
thought
and when the theory is checked against
eyewitness accounts there's more
evidence
the survivors with the best position to
see any breakup were three men on the
AFT boat deck their statements recall
the funnels falling away from the ship
but no large-scale disintegration
and certainly no snapping into
bill and his colleagues around the
country have much more work to do before
they arrive at final proof
but in their view there's simply no
other way to explain the evidence
to them one thing is beyond doubt
Titanic did not separate anywhere near
the surface
powerful new theories the investigation
is beginning to pay off
the mountain of data from the Expedition
has allowed us to drain the ocean
create a new view where we can spot
Clues others may have missed
all the key events of the disaster
traces on the wreckage or on the seabed
they're here for us to see
clues that are bringing the final
Mysteries of the Titanic to crisp Focus
while investigators now have a sharper
understanding of the history of the
wreck
one key mystery they still hope to
unravel
what will happen to the Titanic in the
future
this is the exposed Titanic as she looks
today after A Century Of Decay in the
dark depths
[Music]
in the 30 years since she was found
no one's been able to see her quite like
this
as Titanic investigators study the model
Expedition data and video
it's becoming clearer
month by month
year by year
the ship is disappearing
and it's happening faster than some
experts expected
has been going to the wreck for three
decades
he's seen a big change over time
the distance between the a deck and the
B deck was easily
10 feet now is five six feet and step by
step the deterioration is going close to
the bridge
for the texture will collapse on each
other and everything inside will be lost
forever
investigators want to know why it's
happening so fast
at these depths there's very little
oxygen in the water so metal should rust
extremely slowly
yet on the Expedition footage they can
clearly see the ship caked in weird
formations that certainly look like some
kind of rust
they call them rusticles
I was absolutely stunned by the size the
colors they're very orange and brown and
yet when you're close to them they're
greens and purples and reds and yellows
and every color of the rainbow in the
lab they x-ray pieces of rusticle
recovered from the ship
what they find inside isn't what might
be expected
this is no ordinary rust the structure
inside this hard looking shell is
extremely fragile
they're filled with millions of ducks
and tunnels and passageways and all of
these little cavities and all sorts of
nutrients are stored in there
for the microbiologists on the team it's
Crystal Clear the rusticles are formed
by living organisms
and when they run further tests there's
no doubting what these organisms are
bacteria
we found five different communities of
bacteria living inside of Rascal and
then you've got another community living
on the outside makes them a very complex
little beast
some of these little beasts are
anaerobic bacteria life forms that don't
need oxygen to survive
instead for their energy Supply they
extract iron and minerals from the
ship's metal work
a swarm of microscopic piranhas billions
upon billions of them are feeding on the
wreck
[Music]
the impact of the rusticles on this
extremely large ship is overwhelming
by studying these tiny creatures the
microbiologists can now confidently lay
down a time frame for the Titanic's
final destruction if we went back in 500
years Titanic would look fairly similar
to what the bow section looks right now
as far as the hull would be it would
still be a very u-shape very formal
looking docked ship however I would
expect the deterioration to move from
the back to the front so that a lot of
the Promenade at deck would have fallen
onto itself
if we were to revisit Titanic in a
thousand years
I would not be able to tell sort of the
size of the Magnificent ship that she is
today
I would expect that all of the decking
would be gone and the bow would be
filled with what would look like sort of
piles of rust
if you Revisited the student section you
would see that the deterioration had
greatly increased simply because of the
damage that section had sustained during
the sinking
the bacteria would have taken girders
and basically had encrusted them in
rusticles and deteriorating to the point
of being a pile of iron ore at the
bottom of the seafloor
long before that happens the Titanic's
custodians will have to make tough
decisions
what do we do is do we stand by and
allow the bow section to collapse upon
itself or in the future do we actually
design some projects for recovery
of certain types of artifacts of from
the bow section
but any suggestion of bringing up more
artifacts is controversial
for some descendants of those who lost
their lives the this is a grave site and
should be left alone
initially David Gallo agreed
but since the objects have been put on
display he's less sure
we went to see the Titanic exhibit
and I realized then what a powerful
storytelling method it was to have some
of those artifacts with you so you could
just you could show someone
for me charity facts are the historical
memory of the show
leave everything on the bottom of the
ocean forever and it will be lost
however badly the Titanic deteriorates
one thing certainly thanks to the new
science much of the ship can now never
be lost
the edge of the site's been defined for
the first time so its archeology can be
protected
every inch of the wreck inside the
perimeter has been scanned and analyzed
every known artifact law mapped and
captured in this
in this look at world that will never
erode
Frozen in time we can see and study the
wreck like never before
in broad daylight
explorers now and in the future
can continue their investigation here on
the drained ocean floor
the Thai tent rests
[Music]